How do we prevent an AI apocalypse?
The Dutch philosopher Spinosa once said
that peace is not an absence of war.
It is a virtue, a state of mind,
a disposition for benevolence,
confidence,
justice,
all the great systems we have in our
lives exist only because people who had a
vision of a more beautiful world,
we'll them into reality through hard work.
We've created layers and layers
of these systems, systems of law,
of transportation, of social
interaction, of health care,
and they've been entirely reliant on
human intelligence for thousands of years.
In the past few decades,
though,
we've begun the process of creating
machine intelligence to improve them.
The first phase involved
rule based intelligence,
a series of if then statements,
whether using a traffic light instead
of a human traffic controller or an
automatic fair calculator. Instead of
trusting a driver for a fair price,
we've collectively put our
trust into machine intelligence.
Whereas before we had to trust humans.
It was scary at first.
Initially we didn't understand
how the technology worked,
but eventually it became the norm.
We found that it made the system better.
If we trusted the machine to do the job.
We then moved on to using heuristics.
In the next phase, our machines
started making educated guesses,
whether that be finding the shortest
path between two points or predicting the
most likely weather for tomorrow.
We again learn to trust
them to do those jobs well.
Now we're in the last phase,
the learning phase.
We began teaching our machines had
to learn for themselves. Eventually,
our cars will learn to
drive themselves chemists.
We'll be able to teach their machines
to discover new drugs for themselves.
Every single system we built up until
now will eventually be able to learn for
itself just like we do.
But should we trust our learning systems?
What happens when we solve intelligence
entirely and what does a benevolent
superintelligence look like?
The famous Dutch painter,
Rembrandt used to roam
the streets of Amsterdam,
finding inspiration in these canal walk
waits for some of his greatest pieces in
his studio. He would ask the
students to try and emulate work,
work that took him decades
of training to create.
We can now condense all that training
time using machine intelligence so that a
novice can emulate his style
instantly and that goes for any skill.
We'll all be able to master any
skill instantly by augmenting our own
intelligence with machines.
Our world and its current state
though is filled with suffering.
Life is hard even for the most well
off the ultra rich purchase material
possessions to account for the
loss of what really matters,
the loss of connection,
the loss of intimacy,
the loss of community AI can change that.
It can end suffering as we know it
entirely. Enabling Utopia on earth,
ending all war and disease,
using insights that only a
super intelligent machine
could give us in a matter
of seconds. Then girl once said, for my
part, I know nothing with any certainty,
but the side of the makes me dream.
He actualized his dreams using a canvas
and soon we'll be able to actualize our
own using AI as our canvas.
Whether that means generating entirely
new realities to live out our wildest
fantasies in or creating a universal
problem solver where given any objective
function, it can optimize for
it by minimizing an error value.
But who gets to decide what that objective
function is for all the good that AI
could bring us? There's also the
possibility of it being used for evil.
Holland is world renowned for its
tolerant attitude and openminded spirit,
but just a few decades ago,
it's own police and civil service
forces were used to transport tens of
thousands of Jews to
extermination camps in Germany,
including Anne Frank and her family.
Adolf Hitler was able to manipulate
hundreds of thousands of people into
believing his own twisted ideology if
Hitler was able to get his hands on
superintelligence.
We all be living in a nightmarish reality.
As generative models improve,
the ability to manipulate
people is becoming easier.
Moneyed interests have already begun
conducting surveillance of our actions and
analyzing our data to build a
weaponized AI propaganda machines.
And these machines are used to manipulate
our opinions and behavior in order to
advance political agendas in a way that's
never before been possible on AI could
even come up with an objective of its own.
And that objective could be to
annihilate our species entirely.
This can happen directly because it
desires to end human life or indirectly in
the way that we build canals to make
transport more efficient for us and in the
process destroy countless
ecosystems of insects.
So how do we ensure that the AI
we create is beneficial and safe?
Superintelligence is by its
very definition smarter than us,
able to reason at a level so different
from us that it's literally unimaginable.
We could try and contain it to
block it from Internet access,
but eventually it will learn to escape.
And if one person doesn't let
their AI escape, another one will.
We shouldn't try to stop progress in Ai.
Instead,
we need to ensure that it's
aligned with our own values.
We need to understand exactly how these
algorithms work so they produce the
results that we want.
But who's to say what good values are?
Should we be allowed to pay for
sex or consume any drug we want.
We can't even collectively
decide on what good and evil is.
Philosophers have been
debating what constitutes both
for thousands of years and
AI lives on both sides of that debate.
Viruses will use AI to learn how to
best break into security systems,
but at the same time,
security systems will use AI to learn
how best to defend against threats.
Ai will increasingly be used to create
fake but realistic looking news,
but at the same time,
AI will also get better at detecting
what's real and what's fake.
We're in the midst of a new arms race
and AI is the nuclear power of our time.
As soon as any institution be
it government or corporation
learns of the power
of Ai, they will to use it to
fulfill their own interests.
We can learn a lot from our past.
The European enlightenment era writer,
Lord Acton had words that
still ring true today.
He said that freedom consists
of the distribution of
power and despotism and its
concentration.
We must democratize this AI power.
We must make it as accessible
to as many people as we can.
That way the will of the collective
will override any one bad actor.
And only by educating ourselves on
how exactly this intelligence works,
will we be able to better align it
with our intended goals is there,
it's up to us to ensure that our AI
values all the things that we do,
that he cherishes laughter and connection,
that it preserves friendship and love.
In our quest to understand intelligence,
we'll learn more about who we are
and what it means to be human.
And together we'll finally be able to
take that most sublime process guided by
nature into our own hands.
Evolution.